jimmy pop and jared from the bloodhound
gang tell me about the show what do you
want to do you got an announcer
and then you want to get on the air and
do you want to do you want to play music
do you want to talk what do you want to
do
a little bit of everything and uh can i
introduce you to the announcer we were
thinking about for the show
yeah go ahead his name is uh mark he's
uh they call him
at the grocery store near us all right
hey so so here you step up to the
now this is your announcer yeah this is
our announcement mark
this is a mark from the park aka the
bagger hey mark
what's going on howard how you doing now
you sound like you'd be a good announcer
because you have a different sound
yeah yeah he's very unique very
identified your name is mark
yes what mark uh now have you ever done
professional announcing
no no tell him tell howard your real
name i'm the bagger
all right the bag the beggar and you
work at a grocery store yes all right
and tell me what your responsibilities
are
uh bag groceries and get cards okay and
when you get a cart and you get
groceries do you get tips
yes you do and when you get these tips
do you make a lot of money are you
saving your money
yes do you have your own home no i never
my mother
you live with your mom yeah and you're
you're uh it's not a high-profile job is
it hard to get women are you a
heterosexual
no he's bothered by yeah how did you
meet the great bloodhound gang i mean
these are very big rock stars i met him
about
uh three years ago through my agent you
have an agent
what do you personally tell me to say
that let me just tell the blood how i'm
getting something right away
a this guy can't be your announcer
because he's my announcer
this guy's a genius we don't even
deserve a show
forget you you you write your own show
yes how old a guy are you
i'm 30. are you a fan of the bloodhound
gang yes you are
and did you go to their show is that how
you met them yes yes and we actually
grew up right down the street
i see so so these guys are your pals yes
would you screw us over to be on howard
show
no you want users i want you on my show
okay hal i love you you're my man now
um let me tell you something why would a
grocery bagger have an agent that i
don't understand
he just found me one day one night in
the barn we just hooked up
no his agent is actually one of the guys
that works for us
have you gotten other work some sort of
show business work this mtv
mtv you were on yes okay now you
understand that if you become
part of the bloodhound gang's new show
you'll have responsibilities
yes i want you to treat your job in a
serious manner now can you show up every
day
and be on time yeah are you willing to
walk away from your lucrative baggage
career yes you are to be the announcer
on the show you want to get out of the
bagging
yes have you ever had a time when you
were bagging groceries and you wheeled
out a
fairly attractive woman's groceries and
she said listen mark i've got to have
you
sexually no never have no don't lie
he has actually had he has actually had
sex in the dumpster behind the athlete
with a man or a woman a woman a woman
how'd that happen how many
how many women have you had sex with uh
three or four how many guys
uh two two guys what did you do to the
guys i [ __ ] them